are you serious dude what'd i get right
everything hey guys it's vadim with max
tech and today i am a happy guy
because apple has finally redesigned
their imac
and i actually got quite a few of the
predictions from yesterday's video
correct and i'm pretty sure that i was
the only one in the tech space
who thought that the chin might actually
stick around but anyway in this video
i'm gonna go through everything new with
the apple silicon imac i'm gonna talk
about what i got wrong and what i got
right
and then i'm gonna talk about when we
should be expecting the larger imac
with the m1x chip so let's get right
into it
starting from the top the imac looks
great in seven
different colors which john prosser
basically nailed with that leak
it's also incredibly thin precisely just
11.5 millimeters thick which is
surprisingly
even thinner than just the bottom half
of the macbook pro
which is mind-blowing and if you're
wondering how apple achieved this
i explained it in yesterday's prediction
video where i mentioned that basically
everything would be soldered onto the
main logic board
drastically reducing the size since
there's not going to be discrete
graphics in all of the other components
needed for the power hungry intel chips
and the crazy part was that they were
able to fit it all
behind the chin which i'm glad i was
right about the only detail i got wrong
was that i thought it would be
drastically thinner
and i wasn't expecting them to remove
the apple logo
or cover the entire front with a single
sheet of glass
which honestly looks amazing and another
thing i didn't expect at all was that
apple would take the power supply
out of the body and connect it to the
all new
color matched and braided power cable
and wow that magnetic connection feature
is definitely hinting at maxsafe coming
to the redesigned macbooks
and it's awesome that they were able to
pack a gigabit ethernet port into the
brick
as an upgrade option from the base model
i'm also glad that my prediction that
the m1x chip wasn't ready was correct
even though i said there was a small
chance that we could see it happen
but it looks like we're sticking with
just the m1 ship
on this imac another prediction i made
was that the imac would pack in
a fan but apple actually put in two of
them
which is a bit surprising but i'm glad
to hear that it'll be a whisper quiet
10 decibels under typical use this means
that both of the fans will always be
running
just like the current m1 mac mini does
right now the only difference is that
apple probably
redesigned the fans to make them super
quiet at idle speed
another shocker was when apple claimed
that the new six speaker system on this
imac
has better speakers than any mac ever
which is surprising because the speakers
on my current imac pro
are incredible but with two subwoofers
that cancel out each other's vibrations
along with a dedicated tweeter
on each side i totally believe that the
sound quality is going to be incredible
so if you want to see comparison to the
current imac pro
speakers which are the best speakers out
of any mac
click the subscribe button below so you
don't miss out as far as the stand it's
now squared off
which basically everyone was expecting
and of course
it's permanently attached to the imac
just like we thought it would be
and it's nice to hear that you can still
order an imac with a vase amount adapter
instead of the stand now as far as the
ports i got them
completely wrong i thought that we'd
basically have the same ports as the
21.5 inch imac
with the sd card slot and usb a ports
but apple chose to go with up to four
usbc ports
with just two of them supporting
thunderbolt as well as a headphone jack
on the side
which is very convenient it's also very
interesting that the base model only
gets
two thunderbolt ports which requires a
totally
different motherboard compared to the
more expensive models
so it looks like my theory on why there
were two leaked imac
identifiers within beta code turned out
to be right
as far as the display the 24 inch size
leaks were correct and i
am extremely happy that my 4.5 k
display resolution prediction was
correct since 5k
is definitely overkill for a 24 inch
display
so i based my prediction on apple
hitting a target of 218
pixels per inch which they did with 4.5
k resolution
except for some reason i totally messed
up and i thought that it would have a 16
by 10 aspect ratio
but at least i got the 4480 horizontal
pixel count spot on
another prediction i got right was the
1080p facetime camera
and because of the m1 chip it should
look incredible
with new software features added thanks
to the new neural engine
and something that surprised me was that
they said
that this imac will have the best
microphone system in any mac
using a three microphone array with
beamforming
and yesterday's video i also claimed
that apple would color match the
keyboard and the mouse
to the imac body color that you choose
so i'm glad that i was right
but man there are gonna be a lot of
different skus
however one thing that i got totally
wrong
was that i did not believe that apple
would be able to get touch id
into the magic keyboard since it would
require your sensitive data
to travel to the imac wirelessly but i
guess that apple was able to figure it
out
i personally thought that they would go
with face id instead
since we had some leaks within macos
beta code but i guess we're gonna have
to wait and see
for maybe larger imacs or the redesigned
macbooks to get face id
now one prediction from yesterday's
video that i got totally spot on
was the starting price of thirteen
hundred dollars
and the reason i thought that was
because that was the price of the retina
4k
21.5 inch model which this new one
directly replaces and yes people are
gonna gladly cough up
thirteen hundred dollars for an m1 chip
powered imac
because of the amazing new redesign
just like i said in yesterday's video
and if you think about it the m1 chip is
already amazing
with an 85 faster cpu than the 21.5 inch
imac models
and a gpu that's 50 faster
than the best vega 20 discrete graphics
option
in some real world we're close and
because it's got the same m1 chip
we have the exact same 8 gigs of ram and
256 gigs of ssd storage
at the base price and up to 16 gigs of
ram
and 2 terabytes of storage which
perfectly matches the options
on the m1 mac mini just as we expected
however there are a couple of
disappointments so let's get right into
those
first off we can't order it until the
last date of this month and it won't
even
ship until the second half of may which
is a huge bummer because we want them
right now
and the second disappointment is the
fact that the base model only gets a 7
core gpu
but it's not that big of a deal because
in our testing with a thermal pad
modded base macbook air the 7 core gpu
wasn't that much slower
than the macbook pros 8 core but i'd say
that the
even bigger disappointment is not
getting the extra two usbc
ports on the base model as well as not
getting the ethernet port
on the power supply that's included and
we also shouldn't be surprised that it
only
officially supports one external display
since that's a limitation with the m1
chip but on the plus side
you do get a usbc to lightning cable in
the box for charging the mouse
compared to the old usb a version now
here's a really interesting detail that
i just noticed
the 24 inch imac comes with 143 watt
power adapter
which is absolutely overkill for the m1
imac
even with the 4.5 k display so because
of that i believe that apple created
this
power adapter with the larger future
imac in mind
so they only have one power adapter for
all of the redesigned imac models
so with that let's finish off this video
with my predictions for the larger imac
that we're expecting to come later this
year i personally have a pretty good
feeling that it's actually going to be
called
the imac pro so the 24 inch imac
will be the only regular imac model and
we're going to have a 30 to 32 inch imac
pro as a replacement for the 27 inch
imac
because of that i believe that the imac
pro is going to be coming this december
since that's when the previous imac pro
and the mac pros
were always released on top of that
it'll most likely come with a chin
since apple kept it for the 24 inch
model but i definitely think that the
overall body size and thickness is not
going to be
nearly as thin because it's going to
need a more powerful cooling system
but i have a good feeling that apple is
gonna reuse the same exact 1080p webcam
the same exact speaker system and the
microphone system as well
but as far as all of the crazy colors i
do not think that the imac pro is
getting those color options
they're gonna keep it very subtle and
neutral like they always do for their
pro
products so probably just space gray or
space black
or maybe even a silver option it's
almost certainly gonna come with a 6k
display and it'll come with the m1x chip
at the base price
the same one that's going to be coming
in the macbook pros
but it's also going to have an option
for an even better chip
potentially the m1z as well as one or
two
dedicated gpu options and in terms of
the pricing i think the apple is going
to be going with a 3 000
starting price for the base model which
is a good middle ground
between the 27 inch imac and the imac
pro
retail prices but i do want to let you
know that it's way too early to know any
of this stuff for sure
but if you enjoyed my predictions for
the 24 inch imac
then definitely click the circle about
to subscribe because we're going to be
getting our hands on those next month
and testing them out and you don't want
to miss it so thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video